[Music]  a training course in the fight against  domestic violence and sexual assault  today the National Institute of crime  prevention held its three-day training  inside the New York New York hotel and  casino focusing on topics like child  sexual abuse human trafficking and  stalking a mixture of Advocates and  community members attended the training  to help provide the proper tools to  those in need  some of the restrooms that should go to  in restaurants or hotels now they're  signs up on the inside if you're a  victim of food and trafficking call this  hotline and so it's got a it's one of  those things people have to know when  they're ready to reach out for help in  special domestic abuse  will experts say the training is open to  law enforcement Educators and victim  Advocates among others who have direct  impact with victims now if you need help  Metro Police has a list of resources  available right now on their website